Let's go next to our caller from the nine
five one area code.
Who's calling today from nine five one and,
uh, where are you calling from?
Hi, my name is Lisa and I'm calling from southern
California.
All right, Lisa, what's on your mind today?
Okay.
I wanted to address the issue of the Census
and the new question about citizenship.
Yes.
Um, this was a topic that interested me very
much during our last, then since in 2010 and
I did a lot of research on it.
And the fact is that the US Census Bureau
is authorized to do a head count and that's
it.
All those questions are voluntary.
You don't have to answer any of them.
That's right.
Yeah.
And so, you know, if somebody doesn't want
to answer their citizenship questions, they
don't have to.
When I filled out my census forms, I didn't
even give our names.
I just gave them how many people were in my
house.
I told them our ages cause I believe that's
important for the congress people to know
there, you know, the, the, their constituency,
the, you know, and I'm also, I gave her income
level because you know, they should know what
services they need to provide as far as kids'
education and senior services and that.
But all those other questions, I left blank
that you know, that, but I'm sure, I'm guessing
that you, so this is an argument for the citizenship
questions shouldn't be on there or is this
an argument for who cares if it's on there?
People don't have to answer it,
right?
Yeah,
no.
Which of which are the two?
Which of the two are you arguing?
Um, the one that, that, um, people don't have
to answer it.
Yes.
No, I know people.
Right.
But the problem is Lisa Jay, not everybody
is going to hear this phone call.
Not Everybody is going to get the message
about voluntary questions.
So the problem is that when you put that question
on there, the whole point of it is that it's
going to dissuade certain people from filling
out the census at all, which will mean those
populations are under counted.
So I completely agree with you.
You don't have to answer it, but it's still
extremely problematic to include the question
and hopefully the, the legal action to try
to stop it will succeed.
Well, I think we need to get the word out
that people don't need to.
I mean, the Census Bureau has no legal authority
to compel anyone.
Yes, I agree.
We've got to get the word out, but you know,
there's 340 million people in this country
and most of them are not going to get that
word and it's certainly not going to come,
uh, a front and center, uh, from the current,
uh, um, administration, that's for sure.
But you're absolutely right, Lisa, and I appreciate
you calling in and, uh, making that call.
On that note.
Yeah,
let me go to a break.
Sorry.
Yet to everybody I didn't get to.
We will take live calls again.
Appreciate you calling it